DAVID BLACK: OK, good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
I am delighted to welcome
Jonathan Powell to Google
today.
Jonathan spent
nearly two decades
mediating between governments
and terrorist organizations.
He runs InterMediate,
a London-based charity
for negotiation
and mediation that
focuses on the most difficult,
dangerous, and complex
conflicts in the world,
where other organizations are
unable to operate.
He was Downing Street chief
of staff with Tony Blair.
And in 1997 he met Gerry
Adams and Martin McGuinness
and became instrumental
in negotiating peace
in Northern Ireland.
In 2008 he suggested publicly
that Western governments
should open talks
with the Taliban,
with Hamas, and with al-Qaeda.
And today he works on different
conflicts around the world
and is the Prime Minister's
special envoy to Libya.
Jonathan has spent
half a lifetime
talking to people in
organizations labeled
as terrorists and has drawn
together his experiences
in his book "Talking
to Terrorists,"
which includes
conflicts from Colombia
to Sri Lanka to Palestine
to South Africa.
So please give a
very warm Google
welcome to Jonathan Powell.
Jonathan.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN POWELL: Thank
you very much, David.
And thank you very much
for inviting me here.
It feels coming from
Westminster a bit
like several
centuries' time travel
to come into this building,
especially someone as old
as me.
So I was Tony Blair's chief
of staff for 13 and 1/2 years,
from when he became leader of
the Labour Party to when he
left Downing Street.
He left by the front door,
I left by the back door.
And during that time I was
also the chief negotiator
on Northern Ireland.
So I spent a lot of time
going backwards and forwards
across the Irish Sea and
meeting Adams and McGuinness
and other, less
salubrious characters.
And when I left
government, I tried
being a banker for a while
but didn't really take
to that, about 12 months of it.
And I carried on trying to
work on terrorism with ETA
in Spain and other conflicts.
And now I set up this
charity, InterMediate,
to carry on doing the work.
And it struck me there were
some lessons to be learned.
And I have to say
I wasn't always
in favor of talking
to terrorists.
The first time I
met some terrorists,
I certainly wasn't in favor.
I met Adams and
McGuinness in 1997.
They had shot my father through
the ear in an ambush in 1940.
The IRA, not Adams
and McGuinness.
My brother, who wrote that
[INAUDIBLE] tripping on a death
list for eight years.
So when I met them
I didn't really feel
like shaking their hands
and refused to do so.
A petty gesture,
which I now regret.
But actually,
interestingly, when
I came to study
past conflicts, this
is one that repeats itself
time and time again.
The first time people
meet from a conflict,
they never want to shake hands.
It takes a long time
to get to that stage.
We went actually on a
walkabout immediately
after that meeting, Tony
Blair in east Belfast,
in a very Protestant
area of east Belfast.
And he was confronted
in the shopping center
by a crowd of old women,
so hell's grannies,
I thought of them as.
And they were
charging him, and they
started throwing
rubber gloves at him.
And he thought maybe it was
a protest about washing up.
But it was because
he hadn't worn gloves
to shake hands with Adams
and McGuinness, these two
murderers.
It was a very visceral issue,
this shaking hands business.
About a week after that
meeting, Martin McGuinness
gave me a call out of the blue.
And he said, would I visit
Northern Ireland incognito?
But would I especially
not tell the securocrats,
their name for the
police and the army.
So I asked Tony Blair,
and he said, yes, go.
So I took a plane to
Belfast and a taxi to Derry.
I stood on a street corner,
feeling slightly foolish
like a character out of
some sort of spy novel.
And then two guys
with shaved heads
suddenly turned up and pushed
me into the back of a taxi.
And the taxi whisked
off and drove around
for an hour around Derry
until I was completely lost.
And pushed me out of the door
just outside a new modern house
on the edge of an estate.
And I knocked on the door.
And Martin McGuinness came
to the door on crutches.
I made a not very funny
joke about kneecapping,
which is the way the IRA used to
punish people they didn't like
by drilling holes through
all of their various joints.
I spent three hours sitting
in that house with him,
and we made no breakthroughs.
The lady of the house had
kindly asked no questions
and left some sandwiches
and a cup of tea.
We made no breakthroughs,
but it started a pattern
of trying to build
some sort of trust
to get out of this
conflict, which had gone on
for-- depending on how you
count it-- seven centuries or 30
years.
There was a huge gap of
trust, and that could only
be built by going
onto their territory,
not demanding that they
come to Downing Street
or they come to Stormont Castle.
So I took from that
the idea that you do
need to be able to
talk to terrorists.
But you do also need to bear
in mind that you'll never
bridge that trust totally.
As I say, for the 10 years I
was crisscrossing the Irish Sea.
But even late in the
negotiations in 2004,
I think it was, we
were negotiating
in a monastery in west Belfast,
in a Catholic area of Belfast.
And we stayed
late, and the monks
had kindly given us
dinner in their refectory.
And we were eating,
and I was worried
about missing the
plane back to London.
And I was looking at my
watch, and the minute hand
had become loose and was
swinging around loosely.
So I couldn't work
out what the time was.
Martin McGuinness
noticed and said,
oh, I've got a watchmaker
at the end of my street.
Give it to me and
I'll get it fixed.
I said, no, honestly, really,
you don't need to worry.
Please don't do that.
But he insisted.
So he took my watch away,
and he gave it back to me
two weeks later at our
negotiations at Leeds Castle.
And I, of course, had to give
it to the security authorities
to check it for
trackers and bugs.
Which they did, and they broke
the minute hand immediately,
and I had to go and get it fixed
very expensively in London.
So there's a limit to how
much trust you can build.
But I was interested
as I started
doing this work as
my full-time vocation
now, giving up everything
else and just doing this.
Whatever I'd learned from
Northern Ireland actually
also applied elsewhere.
So what I've done with
this book is gone back
and interviewed the
people who participated
in similar conflicts
everywhere else in the world,
from South Africa to
Indonesia, the Philippines
to Latin America, El
Salvador, and Colombia.
And there's an interesting
pattern that comes out of it.
And one of the patterns
is that we always
say we won't talk to terrorists.
When we first meet
terrorists, we always
say we'll never talk
to you, as we just
have with ISIS, for example.
In fact, as Dick Cheney put it,
we never negotiate with evil.
We defeat it.
Well, the fact is
if we look back
at the history of
the last 30 years,
or actually more
than that, you'll
find that we don't actually
defeat terrorist groups.
We always end up
talking to them.
And it would be a good thing
if we were able to learn it.
Hugh Gaitskell, who is
leader of the Labour Party,
put it rather well.
He said, the old
terrorists end up
having drinks at the
Dorchester as guests
of Her Majesty's government.
And that's certainly
true of what
happened to Britain
during decolonization.
We called Menachem Begin, later
the Prime Minister of Israel
but at the time the
leader of Irgun,
a terrorist group in Israel that
blew up the King David Hotel,
killing 91 people.
We called him a terrorist.
We tried to gun him down.
Later, we welcomed
him as a statesman.
Jomo Kenyatta, the
leader of Kenya,
we put in jail as a terrorist
in Kenya for five years.
Eventually we negotiated
peace with him,
treated him as a statesman.
Makarios, Archbishop
Makarios in Cyprus, we
exiled to the Seychelles.
But later he was the person
we negotiated peace with.
And yet we never seem to learn
the lesson that we are always
going to end up doing it.
There's a sort of collective
amnesia we need to escape from.
And if you think about
it, terrorist leaders
are just there much
longer than governments.
Gerry Adams has seen eight
British prime ministers
come and go in his time as
leader of the republican
movement.
So not surprisingly, he has
a better sense of perspective
than we tend to have.
Now of course there are
arguments put forward
against talking to
terrorists, and I've
experienced quite a few
of them since publishing
this book in the last few days.
Some of them put quite strongly.
And the first is that
it's appeasement.
George W Bush made a speech in
the Knesset in Israel in 2005
in which he said talking to
terrorists was appeasement.
It was just like Munich.
Seems to me that's a
complete misunderstanding
of appeasement.
The mistake that
Chamberlain made in Munich
was not talking to Hitler.
Talking to Hitler was
a very sensible thing
if you wanted to try and avoid
another catastrophic world war.
The mistake was thinking
you could buy him off
with a slice of Czechoslovakia.
Now talking to terrorists
is not the same
as agreeing with terrorists.
The notion you'd give in to
terrorists because they've
got weapons would
be a terrible idea.
But we sat down
with the IRA, who
were demanding a united
Ireland at the barrel of a gun.
We did not give them
a united Ireland.
What they got was
something quite different.
They got power sharing,
they got the Irish language,
they got north-south bodies.
But unless you sit
down and negotiate,
you won't get to
that compromise.
So the demand the
terrorist makes always
looks unreasonable.
Once you start to
negotiate, you get
into the realm of
the reasonable.
The second argument
put against it
is legitimacy, that we are
giving terrorists legitimacy
by talking to them.
That is true, and it's
something the terrorists crave.
But that legitimacy
is very short lived.
If you take the FARC in Caguan
in 1998 to 2002, the rather
disastrous talks that
were held between
the Colombian Government
and the Marxist guerrillas.
They got legitimacy from
talking to President Pastrana.
But as soon as they
broke off the talks
and went back to fighting,
they immediately lost
that legitimacy and went
back to a worse situation.
Dismissed as
narcoterrorists who rejected
a very reasonable
political offer.
So that legitimacy
is true, but it's
a very short-lived phenomenon.
The third argument
is that we're showing
that terrorism works
if we talk to them.
Jim Prior, who used
to be secretary
of state for Northern
Ireland under Mrs. Thatcher,
said this the other day
that terrorism had worked.
The IRA got what they wanted.
But they didn't get
what they wanted.
And that's the point.
Terrorism works in
terms of getting
attention for what
they want to do.
What ISIS is doing
gets them attention.
It's not going to get
them what they want.
They're not going to get
a caliphate out of this.
But they're certainly
getting attention.
Boko Haram kidnapped 200 girls.
They'd been fighting for
five years before that.
They burned 100 schoolboys
to death in a barracks.
No one paid a blind
bit of attention.
They kidnap 200 girls.
Suddenly they get attention.
They couldn't
believe their luck.
That's what they wanted.
So terrorism does not work,
and by talking to them
we are not making it work.
So governments always
start off saying
they won't talk to terrorists.
They always start off
with a military campaign.
And when the military campaign
shows it's not working,
they think what we
need is one last heave.
If we make a really
big effort, we
will manage to
solve this problem.
And that's of course what
we did in Afghanistan.
The surge in
Afghanistan was supposed
to put the Taliban
on the back foot.
Trouble is the terrorist
groups don't necessarily
agree with you.
They may not feel
they're on the back foot.
They may feel they
can keep on fighting
against conventional
forces indefinitely.
And that you can
pile in your forces,
you know they're going
to go away again.
So this idea of a last heave
tends to be a delusion.
There are some
revisionist historians,
for example, who claimed
that in Northern Ireland
and with ETA in Spain, if
we hadn't talked to them
and if the government hadn't
insisted on tying the police's
hands behind their
backs on human rights,
we could have defeated them.
Having been engaged in
both of those negotiations,
that's entirely untrue.
It is true that the
IRA were having trouble
getting their attacks through
because we had them penetrated.
It is true that ETA
was being set back
by French police arrests.
But they were not defeated.
They would have
carried on fighting.
And unless we had engaged
with them politically,
we would not have
got to a settlement.
So it is a false argument.
Finally, I think
it's really true
to say there is no alternative
to talking to terrorists.
If you take Hugh Orde, who was
the chief constable, the head
of the police in
Northern Ireland,
he said there's
no example that he
knows in the world of an armed
conflict being policed out.
In the end you have to
find a way of settling it.
General Petraeus said of
Iraq that we couldn't fight,
we couldn't kill
and capture our way
out of an industrial-strength
insurgency.
And that really is true
of all of these conflicts.
The academics have
done work on this
and they say there
are other ways out.
They talk about decapitation.
If you kill or capture
the leader of a movement,
that's supposed to
end the conflict.
Well, it doesn't.
Ocalan, the leader of the PKK,
was captured nearly 10 years
ago now, put in jail in Imrali
on an island in the Bosphorus.
The PKK went from
strength to strength.
Sheik Yassin, the
leader of Hamas,
was killed by a rocket
strike by the Israelis.
Hamas didn't disappear.
It went from
strength to strength.
Decapitation doesn't work.
They talk about Baader-Meinhof,
and Symbionese Liberation Army,
and some of the
smaller armed groups
and say, well, they
were policed out.
Well, they weren't policed
out, but they did fizzle out
because small groups that
disturb middle-class children,
as they were described by
their East German paymaster,
do fizzle out because they
have no real political support.
But if you're dealing with
something like the PLO,
or the FARC, or the
FMLN in El Salvador,
they have real
political support.
They're not going
to just disappear.
The one example put
forward as a way
of solving a terrorist
problem which isn't by talking
is Sri Lanka.
The Rajapaksa government
suggested they won,
they beat the terrorists.
And they did.
They managed to finish
off the Tamil Tigers.
But if you look
at the example, it
doesn't really give you
an example for anyone else
to follow in the West.
For two reasons, or
three reasons, actually.
The first is the methods they
used in Nandikadal Lagoon, when
they finished off the
last 50,000 Tamils,
were not methods that we
could ever use in the West
in terms of
indiscriminate slaughter
and disregard for human rights.
The second reason is that the
reason the Tamil Tigers lost
was that their
leader, Prabhakaran,
who had been seen as
this military genius
up until that
moment turned out--
as one of the
Norwegian negotiators
described him-- as
a military fool.
He tried to fight a
conventional fixed campaign
against a conventional army.
Had he fought a
guerrilla campaign,
he would still be out there
in the jungle fighting
and not have been defeated.
And the third reason is that
the political issue has not
been resolved.
The issue of the Tamil
minority is still out there.
As long as that issue is
there, there's the danger
that you'll face another
terrorist campaign.
I hope to God we don't, but I
think it is entirely likely.
And unless that
problem is solved,
it won't prove to be
a lasting settlement.
It is very difficult
for governments
to talk to armed groups,
democratic governments.
You do not want to be seen
to be talking to people
who are killing your
civilians in cold blood.
And usually, therefore, when
they're persuaded eventually
to talk to terrorists,
they do so secretly.
Now John Major very bravely
started a correspondence
with Gerry Adams and
Martin McGuinness
in 1991, a secret
correspondence.
And that correspondence
was going on
at the time of Warrington,
where a bomb went off and killed
two small children.
I was at an event
yesterday in Cheltenham
with the father of one of
those two small children, Colin
Perry, a very brave man.
And he was describing
the death of his child
and his child dying in
his arms from that bomb.
And he said that had
he known at the time
that John Major was conducting
that correspondence,
he would have been appalled
and demanded it stop.
He said by about
six months later
he realized, thank God that
John Major was doing that.
If John Major hadn't been having
that secret correspondence,
we wouldn't have got to
an end to a conflict.
So even a victim like
that, a victim of the worst
thing a parent can
have, sees the reason
why you do it in this way.
John Major actually
appeared in Parliament
and said that at
exactly the time
this correspondence was going on
that it would turn his stomach
to talk to Gerry Adams,
and he never would,
even though he was actually
conducting this correspondence.
When Paddy Mayhew, the
Northern Ireland secretary,
went to the House of
Commons to explain
this when the
correspondence was leaked,
he was convinced he
was going to be sacked,
there would be demands
for his resignation.
Interestingly, both Labour and
Tory benches understood what he
had done and welcomed it.
But it is for that
reason, because
of the fear of publicity, that
these negotiations are usually
conducted by intelligence
agencies in the first instance.
So for the Northern
Ireland case,
the SIS opened a channel
to the IRA in 1972.
And that channel
continued all the way
through to John Major's
correspondence in '91 to '93.
So you start this channel,
and it takes a very long time
to get from the channel
to a real negotiation.
Similar thing happened
in South Africa.
Initial negotiations with
the ANC outside the country
were conducted by the NIS,
by the National intelligence
Service, who did the
hard work to start with.
They met ANC leaders secretly
in various Swiss hotels,
moving around.
Because Switzerland
was the one place
they didn't need to have visas.
And these meetings
are deniable so
that governments can walk away
from them if they come out
and they're embarrassed by them.
It's not just John
Major who did that.
Every Spanish prime minister
since the time of Franco
has had talks with ETA, and
every Spanish prime minister
since the time of
Franco has denied
he is having talks with ETA.
Suarez, the Prime Minister just
after Franco, in Parliament
when asked by the leader of the
opposition, Felipe Gonzalez,
are you conducting
negotiations with ETA?
He said no, I'm not.
Felipe Gonzales said,
but you told me yesterday
privately you were.
And he said no, I'm not.
So prime ministers
and governments
do go out of their way to
deny that these things are
happening.
And governments use deniable
people to conduct them.
The Oslo negotiations
on the Middle East,
one of the most successful of
these sort of negotiations,
was conducted by an Israeli
academic, Yair Hirschfeld,
because if it had been
an Israeli official,
it would've been something
they had to answer for.
As long as it was
a private citizen,
who actually was taking
a risk because it
was illegal at that stage
for an Israeli citizen
to talk to the PLO.
So he was at risk
of being imprisoned.
He took that risk, he
conducted the talks,
but he was totally deniable.
But he got to a
successful agreement.
Governments hate having
to use third parties.
It's counting down, isn't it?
Not up, I'm hoping.
So I thought we were
going on for 41 minutes.
It may feel like that to you.
I thought I was going
to run out of time.
So governments hate
having third parties.
They nearly always try
and drive them out.
The Indian Government
has always hated
the idea of having a third party
working on the issue of Kashmir
and has kept everyone
well out of that.
They even hated
having a third party
in the case of Nepal, a
neighboring country, which they
thought they should
be in charge of.
And when the UN tried to get
involved, they saw the UN off.
And in the end they had to
resolve the issue themselves.
South Africa, they absolutely
refused to have a third party.
They insisted the talks
must be face to face.
But actually,
experience suggests
that third parties
are crucial to getting
to a successful settlement.
The Catholic Church has
traditionally played that role,
particularly in Latin America.
It's increasingly
unwilling to do so.
It sees it as a
politicization, and so they
tend to steer away from
it, for example, in ETA.
The UN, which of course was set
up to do this kind of thing,
had a brief
renaissance of doing it
after the end of the Cold War.
During the Cold War, the
UN couldn't play the role
because everything
was a zero-sum game
between the Soviet Union
and the United States.
So you couldn't have
the UN play that role.
In 1989 they played the role
successfully in El Salvador,
maybe in a few other countries.
But countries soon
got chary about having
the UN coming in and
interfering in its affairs.
So then we moved on
to small countries
doing these sort of
third party negotiations.
Norway did it in the case
of Sri Lanka, for example.
Explicitly in the words of
the Sri Lankan Government,
because they were small,
they were a long way away,
they had no interest,
they could be ignored.
So they weren't too
powerful a third party.
And one of the
interesting things that's
happened in diplomacy
over the last 10, 15 years
is the NGOs, like my NGO, play
this role of intermediaries
because we're deniable, we're
small, we're not powerful,
we're not a threat
to a government.
One of the most interesting
to do that was a group called
Sant'Endigio, which is a lay
Catholic order based in Rome
that played the
role in Mozambique.
They managed to build
the relationship
with RENAMO, this really
quite fearsome group
operating out of the jungle.
They worked with an
archbishop from Beira
called Archbishop Goncalves,
who in his first visit
to go and see RENAMO went
to confession three times
before he left and dressed in
his full archbishop's robes.
And he was flown in a
small jet into the jungle
and met them and managed
to start building trust.
And that Catholic lay
group over four years
managed to get to the end of one
of the most bloody civil wars
certainly anywhere in Africa
and possibly in the world,
with millions who
died and many more
millions who were displaced.
So there is a role
for third parties.
But it's always hard to
persuade governments to do it.
The question arises
of how do you
make contact with
an armed group?
They are deliberately covert.
They are deliberately
trying to avoid
you getting in touch with them.
There's not some
front door you can
go knock on and
offer your services.
So it's quite hard
work to try and find
where these groups are.
Your technology helps
to a certain extent.
When some colleagues of mine
were trying to make contact
with the Nepalese Maoists, they
had no idea where to start.
But they knew the
Nepalese Maoists
had a website called
shiningpath.com, dedicated
to their heroes, the rather
gruesome Maoist guerrillas
in Peru.
So they sent an email to this
website, shiningpath.com,
and were amazed to get a
reply and then gradually
set up a meeting in a deserted
unfinished entire block
in Delhi where they were
taken in a rickshaw and all
this other usual jazz.
And they were taken there
and had the meeting.
So it all started
with a website.
In another case of
Aceh in Indonesia,
where the guerrilla
forces have been
fighting for 30 years, the GAM.
Again, the person
conducting the negotiations
knew the name of
the leader and knew
the leader lived in Stockholm
but had no other details.
So he went through the
Stockholm telephone directory
calling everyone with
the name until he finally
got to the right person.
And interestingly, that
person then wanted to meet.
Because one thing that people
don't necessarily understand
is that leaders of armed
groups have often not
talked to anyone
external for decades.
And they're longing to tell
their story to someone.
They really want someone
to come and talk to them.
So if someone
turns up and knocks
on your door, even
if you suspect them
of being a CIA agent or
whatever it might be,
you are prepared
to talk to them.
And you can actually get started
on building a relationship.
Yair Hirschfeld, who
started the Oslo talks,
had a similarly odd way
of starting the talks.
He gave his mother-in-law's
in Finchley's telephone number
to Abu Ala, his opposite number.
And Abu Ala called it 17 times
and eventually got through
to him.
And they agreed to meet in
a hotel, which was the Ritz.
And Yair wanted to
rent a private room
so they could have a private
meeting, but they had no money.
So they agreed to meet
in the restaurant there.
And what he hadn't realized was
on that particular afternoon
there was a [INAUDIBLE].
So there were elderly couples
waltzing around the room
while the two of them were
trying to negotiate peace
on the Middle East.
So it doesn't always
work out perfectly.
What governments often do
is try to find the guerrilla
leaders where they know
they are, which is in jail.
That's often the easiest
way to start a negotiation
because it's not dangerous
for the negotiator
and you know where to find them.
In Colombia, for example, the
ELN leaders, talks with the ELN
began with them in jail.
The most famous one
was Nelson Mandela,
who was in jail who the
South Africans moved out
of Robben Island
and started talking
to him while he was in prison.
It made his colleagues in
prison very, very suspicious.
But that's really where the
germ of negotiations came from.
And Mandela was wise
enough to realize
that, instead of having
contempt for his oppressors,
he had to engage them
to win their trust.
And ended up with a rather
extraordinary meeting
with PW Botha before
PW Botha stood down.
When Mandela was taken from
jail in a blacked-out car,
they didn't tell the jail
people they were leaving.
They zoomed out,
not because they
were scared of
Mandela being killed,
but they didn't want the other
intelligence agencies to know,
what they called the
brownshirts in South Africa.
And they told the guards on
the Prime Minister's residence
that there was a visiting
dignitary, a president
of another African
country who was coming.
And they whisked him
in up the elevator.
And they had a rather
extraordinary meeting
between these two
old men who'd been
such vicious
enemies for so long.
But in a way started
the peace process.
It does, however, take a
very long time to build trust
and to actually turn any
channel you can develop,
like the one we developed
in 1972, into something
that can be used
for negotiation.
It doesn't happen from
one day to the next.
In the case of Sri Lanka,
a Norwegian politician
called Erik Solheim, who
conducted the negotiations,
had to work for a very long
time with the deputy leader
of the Tamil Tigers
called Balasingham
to get to a relationship
where he trusted him.
And the first step
was Balasingham
had diabetes and needed to get
out of the jungle in Sri Lanka
and be treated.
And the Norwegians tried to
facilitate him getting out
so he could have this operation.
They negotiated with the
Sri Lankan Government.
It didn't work.
So the Tamil Tigers eventually
exfiltrated him to Thailand.
He had a British passport so he
was allowed to come to Britain.
But he still had no way
of having a transplant.
And what Erik Solheim
did was arrange for him
to come to Norway and
have an operation so
that he could actually live.
And that, not surprisingly,
built a relationship of trust.
He had to insist that he brought
his own donor with him who
Balasingham insisted
was a relative,
although he probably wasn't.
Because the idea of
having a Norwegian kidney
would not have gone
down terribly well.
But it was a way
of building trust.
The most difficult
thing often is
to-- In the
negotiations with ETA,
for example, the people
handling the ETA leaders
had to have them
living in their house
for nearly six months,
which with small children
and so on is a kind
of weird thing.
Because these people have
been on the run for years.
They never stayed in the same
house for more than a week
or two at a time.
They missed their own families.
They had never been able
to cook because they
haven't been in a kitchen.
And having this
emotion, and they
have horrors of the torture
they've been through.
Although they are
also killers, which
you want to remember as well.
But so having them
in the house, looking
at them babysitting
the children,
them being allowed
to do the cooking,
spending Christmas
with a grandmother.
Odd things that
you wouldn't think
would be an actual thing
to do for a terrorist.
But if you want to get to a
relationship that takes you
somewhere, that's
what you need to do.
And it takes a long time
in part because it's
an educational function.
You need to help the
guerrillas who've
lived in isolation,
lived in a mental ghetto,
talking only to each other.
You need to help
them get out of that
and start seeing how they're
seen by the rest of the world.
And what may be achievable and
what may not be achievable.
It is not always the
right circumstances
to begin a negotiation even
when you've built that trust.
If a negotiation is
going to succeed,
you need to have at
least what academics
call a mutually hurting
stalemate, where
both sides realize
they're not going to win.
In Northern Ireland
this happened probably
in the mid-1980s.
In the early 1980s,
the British army
came to understand
it could forever
keep the IRA at a certain level.
They could stop their
security becoming
threatening to the state.
But they could
never defeat them.
About the mid-1980s, Gerry
Adams and Martin McGuinness
began to realize that
they could fight forever.
They would never be defeated.
But they were never going
to drive the Brits out
by military force.
They got way past fighting age.
There's a generational
aspect to this.
They started very young.
They were fighters.
They got to their 30s.
They no longer believed
in fighting themselves,
and they could see their
sons, daughters, nephews,
nieces getting arrested
or getting killed.
They could see this
could go on forever.
And at that stage
they reached out.
It's also interestingly a
life-threatening disease
can have an effect
on these things.
Ian Paisley, who had always
been one of the people opposed
to a settlement in
Northern Ireland,
was someone who
actually helped start
the fighting in the
first place by trying
to march on west Belfast.
He went into the hospital in
2004 and very, very nearly
died.
He came out physically
completely different,
very thin, very, very stark.
And he told us afterwards
he'd had a close encounter
with his maker
while in hospital.
And he decided he wanted to
end his life as Dr. Yes rather
than Dr. No.
So when he came out, he took a
completely different reaction
to the negotiations.
He tried to get to an agreement.
Every time we had
a meeting, he'd
be trying to get to an
agreement and his party
would be pulling him back,
trying to stop him doing it.
We saw that also
with Hugo Chavez.
Hugo Chavez, who had been
instrumental in strengthening
the FARC, allowing the FARC to
base themselves in Venezuela.
When he got cancer,
he not only started
going to church twice a day.
He also actually
dedicated himself
to trying to bring an
end to the war with FARC
by pressing the FARC to
go into negotiations.
So you can have these
odd personal effects
to start the negotiation going.
And you need most of
all to have leadership.
You need to have politicians
on both sides who
are ready to take risks.
In his book, Tony Blair
says that I accused him
of having a messiah
complex, and that's
why he managed to
solve Northern Ireland.
It wasn't quite that.
It was Mo Mowlam.
You're probably all too young
to remember who Mo Mowlam was.
But she was very colorful,
quite earthy Northern Ireland
secretary.
And it was she who actually
said to me that Tony thought
he was fucking Jesus,
which is not exactly
the same thing as a messiah
complex but in the same range.
And there is an element to that.
If you're going to have a leader
who wants to solve a conflict,
they have to believe that
it can be solved and believe
that they can solve it.
Mrs. Thatcher did not believe
that Northern Ireland could
be solved, so she was
never going to do that.
John Major believed
it could be solved
but didn't really believe
he could solve it.
You need people who have this
belief that it can be done.
And you need them on both sides.
It's one of the reasons the
Middle East process gets stuck
in a rut when you
don't have leadership
of that sort on both sides.
But we did luckily
in Northern Ireland.
And of course, classically
in South Africa,
where you had that leadership
from Nelson Mandela.
Without it, you
would never have got
to a peaceful outcome
for South Africa.
And if you hadn't
actually had it
on the side of FW de Klerk,
if he hadn't seen the need
to negotiate rather than
his predecessor to fight.
There is an art to
these negotiations
once you start them.
Again, looking
back at the pattern
of all these previous
negotiations,
they're not simple things to do.
There are certain rules
you have to follow.
I had no training
in negotiation.
I joined the Foreign
Office in 1979.
And the training
consisted of one day.
And we were given a copy
of Harold Nicolson's book
"Diplomacy," which is a
wonderful British book.
It was published in 1939
and republished in 1948.
And the 1948 edition has a
rather wonderful understatement
in the first line.
"A number of serious events
have taken place in the world
since this book was
first published."
[LAUGHTER]
Which is indeed true.
The only other training we were
given we were given a guide
to [? plasmon. ?] And
[? plasmon ?] is where you
should sit people
at dinner parties,
which is very
important in diplomacy.
But we were given no
training in negotiation.
So I've had to learn
it as I've gone along.
But it is interesting
that people prepare.
If you're going to fight a
military campaign, you prepare,
you have a strategy,
you have a plan.
If you're going to run
a political campaign,
you have a strategy,
you have a plan.
People go into negotiations
without any plan at all.
It's true of business as
well as in this sort of work.
And you do need to have a plan.
And the first thing
you need to learn
in this sort of negotiation
is the importance of process.
I wrote a book on Northern
Ireland when I left government.
And they allowed me to go
back through all of the files.
And I sat in this little
office underneath the Cabinet
secretary's office reading
all these old files.
And there's one thing that
leaped out of those files
at me more than
anything else at all.
And that was the
need for process.
When there was a process in
place, then there was hope
and you believed you
could get to a settlement.
When there was no process,
there was a vacuum,
and the violence started again.
So making peace is not an event.
It's not some big thing
where you have a celebration.
It's actually that process
that gradually builds trust
over a very long period of time.
Shimon Perez, recently
the President of Israel
who is a master
of the one-liner,
sums this up very well.
He says, in the
Middle East everyone
knows what the outcome
of Arab-Israeli peace
will be in terms of territory,
in terms of refugees,
even in terms of Jerusalem.
But there's no
process to get there.
And he says, the
good news is there's
light at the end of the tunnel.
And the bad news is
there's no tunnel.
What you're trying
to do as negotiators
is create that tunnel so you can
actually get to a settlement.
I think of it also
as a bicycle theory,
that if you can get a
process going like in Libya,
where I work,
we've just started.
We finally in the
desert last week
got the two sides to
sit down together.
If we can keep
that process going,
if we can keep that
bicycle moving forward,
and we don't let them
go back to fighting,
and we make it really hard
for either side to walk out,
there's a chance we
can get to a success.
So it's like keeping
the bicycle moving
but not letting it
fall over at any stage.
And that can
involve a great deal
of personal pain
and political pain.
And I remember in 2004
in Northern Ireland,
we had just failed to get an
agreement with Ian Paisley.
The whole thing had collapsed.
Everyone had walked
away from the talks.
I went over to west Belfast
to meet Adams and McGuinness.
I got off the plane.
And I was met by a senior
official who took me
a mile in the car and then
stopped the car and got out
so the driver couldn't hear
what we were saying and said,
last night there
was the biggest bank
robbery in world history
at Northern Bank.
And the dogs on the street
know the IRA carried it out.
And I was just about to
meet Adams and McGuinness.
I was absolutely furious.
I went over and kicked a
rock and stubbed my toe
and thought I'd go back
to London on the plane.
But I decided that actually that
would be the wrong thing to do,
even though I was out on a limb.
Everyone else thought it was
stupid to carry on the talks.
The only thing to do was
to keep the process moving.
So I went along to meet
with Adams and McGuinness.
I couldn't even
mention the crime
because it hadn't been
made public at that stage.
So I couldn't say
anything to them about it
like, you bastards.
So I met them and I
had the conversation.
And we kept the process going.
And in retrospect, that
was the right thing
to do to try and make sure
that things keep moving along.
There are all sorts of things
I'd like to say to you,
but I'm more interested really
in hearing your questions.
So I'm going to cut to the end.
Just let me touch on the future.
As I've already said, when
I left government I said,
on the basis of what I
learned in Northern Ireland,
we should be talking to Hamas,
the Taliban, and to al-Qaeda.
And I was rubbished by my
former colleagues in government.
They said, this is nonsense.
They are quite different
from the PLO and the IRA
and we shouldn't be
talking to these groups.
In the intervening
six years, we've
now had negotiations
with the Taliban
for the release of Sergeant Bowe
Bergdahl and other negotiations
behind that.
There have been negotiations
with Hamas, Israel,
and the United
States on a ceasefire
and on the release
of Gilad Shalit.
And the former head of MI5,
Eliza Manningham-Buller,
says that we should be
talking to al-Qaeda.
So these groups,
which six years ago
were too difficult to talk to,
suddenly now we think it's OK.
And this is the trouble.
Every time we come
to a new group,
it's a complete
revelation to us.
And we never look back
at what we did before
and learn the lessons
of what had gone before.
Now of course, groups
like al-Qaeda and ISIS
are more vicious.
They want to kill more
people than IRA or ETA.
They would kill 20
people at a time.
ISIS wants to kill hundreds,
thousands if they can.
Likewise al-Qaeda.
But that doesn't actually make
a difference to terrorism.
Terrorism is still horrific.
The picture of the execution
of a single journalist
is just as horrific and just
as effective for the terrorists
in terms of the terror that it
causes as killing 1,000 people.
So we're dealing very much
with the same sort of thing.
People argue that because
they're religious,
this means that we can't
make peace with them.
There's no evidence
of that at all.
Peace has been made with GAM
and the MILF in the Philippines.
Both of them were Islamic
movements, both of them
had unacceptable demands.
This notion that these groups
are nihilistic and different.
That's just because we don't
understand their reasoning.
And unless you sit
down with them,
you're not going to understand
what their rationality is.
The evidence shows that
terrorists are not psychopaths.
There may be
psychopaths among them
as there are among all
sorts of groups of humans.
But the fact is they have
their own rationality.
They're doing something
to get attention
for what they think they
want to have attention for.
We're not pardoning them.
What they do is unforgivable.
But if you don't understand
their rationality,
you're not going to find a
way of dealing with them.
Maybe we'll leave the discussion
for ISIS for the questions.
But if we really think
we're going to defeat ISIS
by bombing, we're
sadly mistaken.
So let me just give
you my conclusions.
Firstly, that terrorism
is not going to go away.
We keep hoping it's
going to go away.
We keep hoping we'll
find a magic answer,
that drones or
jungle-penetrating radar
will solve the problem for us.
It doesn't.
They just move on to the
next bit of technology.
We use Facebook and other
things to trace them.
They use Facebook to
communicate without us
being able to get them.
There's always a race like this.
And interestingly, it goes back
if you look after the First
World War, there's
a similar thing
with terrorists
and globalization.
So there isn't going
to be a magic answer.
In a way, terrorism is the
evil twin of democracy.
We'll have it as long
as we have democracy
because there are
people who feel
they can't get their
way in democracy.
And there are limits
to what we can
do to try and
suppress such groups.
Experience shows that you will
not get to peace in one day.
You don't suddenly sit
down with ISIS tomorrow
and negotiate peace.
It takes a very long time.
In Northern Ireland, there were
the Sunningdale talks in 1973.
Seamus Mallon, leader of the
SDLP, the Catholic moderate
party, said, the Good
Friday Agreement in 1997
was Sunningdale
for slow learners.
And in a sense it was.
It had the same
elements as Sunningdale.
But you had to wait
that long to get there
because you'd had the
failure of Sunningdale,
the failure of the
Anglo-Irish Agreement in 1985,
the failure of the Downing
Street Declaration in 1993.
And only with the
Good Friday Agreement
did you get to an agreement.
Same with ETA in Spain
from 1974 onward.
So don't expect to
get to it with one go.
But I do believe that
all conflicts are
capable of resolution, even
Middle East peace process.
If you keep going at
it, you'll get there.
Just because it has
failed before doesn't mean
it will fail again.
There is no such thing
as an insoluble problem.
And an interesting
thing happens.
As you approach an agreement,
up to that moment everyone has
said that it's
insoluble, there's
no way it's going
to be resolved.
Suddenly when you solve
it, it's inevitable.
It was always
going to be solved.
There was no problem.
It was the fact that 9/11 or
whatever it was that changed.
They're both wrong.
No problem is insoluble.
And no problem is inevitably
going to be solved.
Because if you just
sit there waiting
for the force of
history to change it
or for something to
happen, it won't go away.
You have to address
it, and you have
to find a way of
doing something.
And the only way
you can do it is
if you have political
leaders who've
got patience, who have the
understanding of what happened
before so they can learn the
lessons of that, have courage,
and we don't try and reinvent
the wheel every time.
So I wish you all read my book.
Thank you very much indeed.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID BLACK: Thank you.
Thank you for an
absolutely fantastic talk.
You can see the
audience spellbound.
JONATHAN POWELL: Only
two or three asleep.
DAVID BLACK: I'm sure people
are keen to ask questions.
So please, line up at the mics.
And to start us off while
people get to their feet.
Let's ask you of your views
on the role of technology
in finding peace.
And the role of technology
in some of the processes
that are going on,
from terrorists
using mass media or social media
to governments increasingly
using increasingly
advanced technology.
What's the role of
technology in this?
JONATHAN POWELL: Well,
the role of technology
is interesting if you look
at it through history.
You can see the videos on
YouTube now of the executions.
So they know very cleverly
how to use technology
to get the maximum impact
for what they're doing.
Their production values
are very upscale.
And there's been this sort
of technological race all
the way through history.
I was saying, David, earlier
the original Fenians back
in the 19th century started
off using gunpowder.
So they would try and blow
up buildings using gunpowder.
And gunpowder is
not very efficient.
There's a famous
occasion when they
tried to blow up
Clerkenwell Prison.
They turned up with a
barrel, and they lit the fuse
three times, and
it wouldn't go off.
So they put it on a
wheelbarrow and took it home
and then brought it
back the next day.
When they did eventually light
it, it blew up the wrong way
and blew out a
tenement building,
killing a large
number of children.
When they invented
dynamite a few years later,
that revolutionized the Fenians.
They were able to use a small,
easily controlled substance.
And they started attacking
all over the place.
Interestingly, attacking
exactly the same things
that were attacked
by later terrorists,
including a Tube train at
the same station as 7/7,
the Glasgow gas works,
and the Hammersmith bridge
that was attacked
by the IRA later on.
The Provisional IRA transformed
itself by using semtex.
So they stopped using dynamite,
they used a colorless,
odorless explosive.
So technology can
change in that way.
But we keep thinking
that somehow there's
an answer, as I said
earlier, the technology.
Because there isn't.
Because there's just this
race, always the race.
So security forces
come up with a way
of frustrating bombs
operated by telephones.
They'll come up with another
way of operating a bomb.
So technology is not
the answer, but it
does keep revolutionizing
what they do.
DAVID BLACK: Thank you.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: Interesting
follow-on question
from that is the role
of Google especially,
because the tools we create
can be used on both sides
and show up are being
used on both sides.
What do you think a company
like Google is uniquely placed
to do?
Like what should we be thinking
about to try and make the world
a safer place?
JONATHAN POWELL: Well,
that's quite a hard question.
I mean, you're not going to
frustrate terrorism by Google.
If you try and chase
the terrorists,
they'll simply find another way
of downloading their messages.
I think actually by
demystifying things
is the way that really helps.
That if people can communicate.
People sometimes think that
globalization, as I say,
is a threat to it.
If people can
communicate more widely,
that's making it more dangerous.
That was true, as I said,
after the First World War.
That's when telegraphs
were invented, steam ships,
communications got much better.
And the anarchist groups
operating in Chicago,
and those operating in Italy,
and those operating in Russia
all shared the same ideas.
So it helped them share
ideas, but it also
helps in fighting terrorism
if there's more transparency
and ideas spread.
So if you're dealing
with Islamic extremism,
if people can actually get
access to that information
much more easily as they can
through the net and other means
like that, it could
make a real difference.
So I don't see a
CT role for Google.
I'm sure some of my former
colleagues in government
would like to.
But I think it's much
more about the ability
to spread information
and demystify things that
are clearly crazy
that would help.
DAVID BLACK: Thank you.
Adam.
ADAM: So you spoke
about leadership
being really important
to resolving conflict.
Just wondering
how you would mark
the leadership of Mr. Cameron
and Mr. Obama with the current
struggles that are happening?
And also, maybe if you don't
see leadership coming from them,
where you do see it coming from?
JONATHAN POWELL: I'm
always loath to be
too critical of
people in government
because I know how
difficult it is when you're
faced with the
decisions in government.
But there is a little
bit of illogicality
in launching a campaign against
ISIS that simply involves
bombing because no one,
including President
Obama or David
Cameron, thinks you're
going to solve the
problem by bombing.
You may be able to stop ISIS
advancing by bombing, and even
in Kobani that's not clear.
Now they're starting to
bomb more systematically,
they may stop the advance.
So I do worry that there's not
a clear strategy thought out
of how they're going
to deal with ISIS.
And they're reacting
to opinion polls,
particularly in
America, that have
moved to very large
numbers for taking action
after the pictures
of the journalists.
But they're doing it without
having, it seems to me,
a clear structure that
can lead to success.
So if you need to have
boots on the ground
to drive these
people out, you're
not going to drive them out of
their defensive emplacements
from the air.
Whose boots do we
really think we're
going to put on the ground?
If it's the Kurds,
well, the Kurds
will advance as far as the
Kurdish areas, Mosul in Iraq
and down toward
[INAUDIBLE] in Syria,
but they're not going
to go beyond that.
The Shia army, the
Iraqi army is not
going to be successful marching
into Sunni territories of Iraq.
So they're not going to do it.
So arming them is not
going to solve the problem.
Arming the FSA, the Free
Syrian Army, on past experience
is not going to
solve the problem.
So what is their answer
for boots on the ground?
For me the answer would lie
in the Anbar Awakening, which
happened when the American
forces were in Iraq when they
got the Sunni tribes to rise
up against al-Qaeda in Iraq
and very successfully
fight back against them.
You need to have someone who's
Sunni who's going to fight.
And I see no effort to do that.
And of course, the Iraqi
Government, which is Shia-led,
does not want to do that because
they fear a Sunni militia.
So the American or
British Government
would have to do that.
There's a certain illogicality
in bombing only Iraq
and not bombing
Syria when ISIS makes
no distinction between
the two of them.
And I would argue
in the longer term,
you're going to have
to talk to them.
You're going to have
to find a way certainly
of talking to the ex-Baathists,
the ex-Saddam generals who
are among their supporters
who don't believe anything
about the caliphate.
They simply feel marginalized by
the sectarian Shia government.
And I see no one making
that effort to talk to them.
We should have been doing
it for the last five years,
and we haven't been doing so.
And in the end, we
will have to talk
to this political
manifestation of extreme Islam.
There is, in my view,
no doubt that there's
real political
support behind this.
Not behind the caliphate,
but between the grievance
that they feel.
And if we don't
address that, if we
don't start building a link now,
trying an educative function
as we have with the
Taliban belatedly,
the trouble is we
do this all too late
and people die unnecessarily.
And General Petraeus
said of Iraq, correctly,
that Americans left
it too late to talk
to people with American
blood on their hands.
If they'd done it earlier,
they'd have saved more lives.
DAVID BLACK: Thank you.
David.
DAVID: Well, first off,
thank you for a great talk.
And thank you for all your work.
I'm rather rare in Google
in that I'm quite old.
And I certainly remember
walking around London
when all the IRA
bombings were going on
and life felt very
different then.
So thank you for that.
I would love to
hear your thoughts
about Russia and the Ukraine.
And does what you've
talked about today
as applied to a situation where,
it's not a million miles away,
but there's sort
of a, shall we say,
a certain legitimacy to
an existing government?
JONATHAN POWELL: Yep.
In my view, the thing that's
missing in the Ukraine
in particular is, or has
been up to now, a willingness
by-- I'm going to leave aside
obvious things like Putin's
aggression, why he's
doing it, and all of that.
But there's one
bit that's missing
and that is the
Ukrainian Government
talking to the separatists
in the east of the country.
They've been very unwilling
to give them legitimacy
by talking to them.
And they've been determined
to try and fight them.
And that's led Putin to come
back in with more armed force.
So the thing that I think
is missing in particular
is that sort of dialogue.
There's some evidence
it's now starting.
But it seems to me it
should have been earlier,
that kind of dialogue
between Poroshenko
and those eastern separatists.
In terms of Putin,
I think we do have
to be very firm in
sending him a message
that we're not going to
tolerate this kind of thing.
Except we always go around
drawing these red lines
and then we're not
prepared to fight for them.
And then they become
very unconvincing.
Saying we don't like what you're
doing, Ukraine, but by the way
we're not going to fight is
not enormously convincing.
But then I'm not
suggesting we should fight.
So I admit they've got
a very difficult task
in Ukraine, the
Western governments.
But the one bit that I would
try and add is that talking bit.
DAVID: And just a follow-on is
should we be talking to Putin,
and what would we
talk to him about?
JONATHAN POWELL: But we
are talking to Putin.
Cameron's calling
him every other week.
President Obama
is talking to him.
The trouble is, I have some
experience talking to Putin.
And it's like talking
to a brick wall.
I remember when Tony Blair
had his last conversation
with Putin in 2007 at the
margins of a G-7 summit.
It was just Tony
and me and Putin
and a Russian interpreter.
And Tony decided
to use the meeting
to tell Putin what
he really thought.
Because we'd been very
early in cultivating Putin
when he was running
for election.
We went out to see him
in Saint Petersburg,
thinking this is the new man.
Let's cut him some
slack and maybe we
can have-- after
Yeltsin-- we can
have some sort of
normal relationship.
And he seemed like a modern
guy, he seemed very warm.
And then I just watched
the hubris time after time.
Every time we went back he
had more horses in his dacha,
more grooms for his
horses, more girlfriends,
and the whole thing became
completely out of whack.
So anyway, Tony in 2007 tried
to tell him like it was.
I would say that Putin
gave it back in spades.
Talking to Putin can feel
quite counterproductive.
DAVID: Hogging the microphone,
can you tell us what he said?
DAVID BLACK: Final question.
JONATHAN POWELL: No,
because I can't remember.
I can't remember.
It wasn't very pleasant.
DAVID BLACK: Thanks.
Let's take some more questions.
Please.
AUDIENCE: How do you make sure
that terrorists do actually
have the power to enforce
an agreement with approval?
JONATHAN POWELL: That's a
very, very good question.
It's one of the first
things you-- Firstly, you
have to persuade people
in the government side
you're talking to
the real thing.
You turn up and
they say, how do we
know these are actually really
the leaders of the terrorists,
not someone who's
telling you they're
the leader of the terrorists?
So you have to ask for
proof, and that's often
quite difficult.
If it's a hostage situation,
you need a video, proof of life,
and things like that.
So first, you have to do that.
And secondly, you
need an organization
that is quite united.
So take Boko Haram in Nigeria.
Boko Haram is very
fissiparous, with lots
of different groups in
the east and the west.
So even if you made peace
with one part of Boko Haram,
it's not at all clear the
other bits would stop fighting.
In the case of Ireland
it was interesting
because our first meeting with
Adams in Downing Street in '97,
at the end of the meeting,
which is very-- sorry,
allow me a digression--
it was an emotive occasion
because this was the
first meeting in what
was called armed
force republicans.
And it was a very tense
day in Downing Street.
And there were more
cameras outside than there
had been when we were
elected in May of that year.
And when they came in,
Adams and McGuinness
were also quite nervous.
And I led them around to the
far side of the Cabinet table.
And they were standing
behind the chairs.
And Martin McGuinness
said to me,
so this is where all the
damage was done then?
And I was actually
horrified, and I said,
yeah, the IRA mortars landed
in the garden behind you,
and they blew the windows in.
My brother was here, and
he dragged John Major
under the table, and four
policemen came in waving guns.
And he said, no, no,
no, I didn't mean that.
This is where Michael Collins
negotiated giving away Northern
Ireland with Lloyd
George in 1921.
So they had a slightly
different historical perspective
on the whole thing.
But anyway, so the
discussion finished.
At the end of that meeting,
Adams took Tony Blair and me
to the end of the room,
the Cabinet room that
had two pillars
that separate you
off from where the table is.
And he said, look,
I could probably
get into peace quite quickly.
But if I do that, I'm going
to split the movement.
We'll end up with
another IRA out there.
If you give me time
and you give me space,
I'll bring the whole
movement with me, or as much
as I possibly can.
And the big bet
that we made, unlike
previous British
governments that had always
tried to split the IRA
into different groups,
was that we would work with
them and try and keep them
together to make peace
once, not to have
to make peace many times.
And I think in the case
of Northern Ireland,
anyway, that was the right bet.
But it's a problem you face with
nearly every terrorist group.
Do they really represent
the whole of the group?
Will their orders
really be followed?
And when they do,
they need to find
ways of ensuring they
actually do what they promise.
And that's another question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JONATHAN POWELL: You're welcome.
DAVID BLACK: Thank you.
Please.
AUDIENCE: In most
of the examples
you gave, governments end up
talking to terrorist groups.
Do you think this is a
tactic of waiting out
until the armed forces
resolve the immediate threat
or until there's less
public attention?
Is waiting a tactic, or is
waiting just governments
being stubborn, of not learning
the lessons of the past?
JONATHAN POWELL: I wish it was
a clever strategy of waiting.
But unfortunately
it's just an inability
to ever remember what
happened last time.
It's quite interesting looking
back at the history of it
because the first real
negotiation with terrorists,
I guess, were with the
original IRA in 1919 to '21.
Lloyd George came, and the
battle started in 1919.
Lloyd George said we will
never talk to this murder gang.
By 1920 it was clear
that it was a stalemate.
The only way the
British could win
was by sending 500,000
troops to Ireland.
So he then started
to try to reach out,
using someone like me,
a guy called Andy Cope,
to try and find the IRA leaders
and start talking to them
and start negotiation.
He then had
negotiations, as I say,
in exactly the same Cabinet room
that we had negotiations in.
About five years later,
British officials in Palestine
were facing a rebellion
led by the mufti.
And they had this
in the paper, you
can read them in the papers.
They had this explicit debate.
Should we learn the
lessons from Ireland?
In Ireland, we did a
deal with a murder gang.
Do we deal with a
murder gang here or not?
They said no, no.
Let's forget about it.
Let's just carry
on killing them.
So they carried on doing that,
and Palestine is still a mess.
So no, I fear it's
not a clever strategy.
It is simply that we
simply don't remember
what happened last time,
which is why I wrote the book.
It is true that you cannot,
you could not possibly sit down
tomorrow and negotiate with
ISIS and come to a conclusion.
That wouldn't work.
It would take time.
All I'm saying is
let's please think
about a long-term strategy
and think about what we're
going to be doing
later so we don't
get a whole lot of people
killed unnecessarily.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JONATHAN POWELL: You're welcome.
DAVID BLACK: Thank you.
Last couple of questions.
Tariq.
TARIQ: First of all, thanks
for coming and sharing
your fabulous stories and
for everything you've done.
JONATHAN POWELL: Thank you.
TARIQ: You've talked all
about building trust.
I'm curious as to
what that actually
looks like in practice.
Because presumably the
first conversations
you had with McGuinness,
Adams over tea and sandwiches
and getting straight
down to business.
There must be some
what might be perceived
at the time as fairly
frivolous conversations.
Can you just replay for us what
some of those conversations
might look like?
JONATHAN POWELL: I'm
not sure I can remember
the sort of details
of them, but I'll
give you one that's
not really frivolous.
But it's an example
of how it can work.
So in 1999 I went to
see Adams and McGuinness
in a house in west Belfast.
I remember because
I was picked up
by a woman who I better
not name, I suppose,
who was supposedly the fifth
member of the Gibraltar IRA
squad.
The other four, you remember,
were shot by the SIS.
She was the fifth member.
She picked me up.
I was carrying a
government briefcase.
And it was so funny
being picked up
by this person who had
been a member of the IRA
with her baby in the
backseat and driving.
It was rather weird.
Anyway, I went to the meeting.
And we were trying to find
a way around this issue
of decommissioning.
The IRA wouldn't agree to
put their weapons beyond use
until the Unionists
shared power.
And the Unionists
wouldn't share power
until they put their
weapons beyond use.
So I talked to some
of our generals
who'd been in Kosovo
and in Bosnia.
And they said what
they did there
was they put the weapons
into sealed containers,
and the UN would go and
inspect them every few weeks.
So they hadn't given
up their weapons.
They still had them.
And the problem with the
IRA was their constitution
said they couldn't
give up their weapons.
So I went to see
Adams and McGuinness
and said, here's this idea
our generals have given us.
What about doing that?
You put your weapons in sealed
dumps, have them inspected.
They said, no way.
There's no way the IRA
council will consider that.
That's out of the question.
Three weeks later, they
came to a meeting with us
in Stormont Castle.
And it was a more formal
meeting with other officials.
And they proposed
the idea to me.
And I said, oh, OK, that's
an interesting idea.
We'll go away and
think about it.
And so that's what
you have to do.
It's not really a
frivolous conversation,
I'm afraid, because
I can't remember
frivolous conversations.
But it was one of the
ways that can work.
SAM: Hi, Jonathan.
My name's Sam.
I'm also really
interested in the nature
of these human
interactions that you have.
Your book is called
"Talking to Terrorists."
I'm curious if you
had the opportunity
to talk to the most
infamous terrorist
of the day, the
so-called Jihadi John.
What would you say to him?
JONATHAN POWELL: Actually,
I wouldn't waste my time
talking to Jihadi John.
He's simply an actor who's
wheeled onto the stage.
And interestingly, quite
a lot of the jihadis
who come from European
countries find the experience
pretty unsatisfactory,
to say the least, what
happens to them
when they go there.
I'd be more interested in
talking to Mr. Baghdadi.
Mr. Baghdadi is an
interesting guy.
He was a local vigilante in his
town near the Jordanian border
in Iraq when American
forces handed him over
to Iraqi security forces,
and he went to Abu Ghraib.
And he came out a pretty
convinced proponent of al-Qaeda
in Iraq.
It's where he had
his conversion.
And actually, he's
clearly a very smart guy
in terms of tactics and how
he runs his organization.
And I'd say to him
that you are not
going to be able to
take and hold territory.
No previous terrorist group
has been able to do that.
So what do you really want?
What are you really
aiming to achieve?
And try and get into
that discussion.
It would take a very long time.
He'd probably behead
me in the meantime.
But it would be that kind of
conversation you need to have,
and it takes a very long time.
DAVID BLACK: Again,
final question, sir.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for the talk as well.
I'd like to ask about
how do you reinitiate
the talks after
something really bad
has happened during
the conflict?
Let's say, example
of now in Gaza,
there's been talk for two
years, but then there's
been this conflict
there this year.
What must happen so that
the talks are reinitiated,
and how does the first
meeting look like?
JONATHAN POWELL: The first
meeting is often very ugly.
I remember talking to
a Tajik Islamist who
had been fighting for 20
years out of Afghanistan
against the Tajik Government.
And him saying the first
meeting was very emotional
because he had
never sat down face
to face with government
representatives before.
And after that he found
it much harder to go back
to killing them.
It really had quite
an emotive effect.
Sometimes in other
places, talking
to the people in the El
Salvador negotiations.
Interesting because they sat
down and, even though they
really, I mean--
Joaquin Villalobos, who
was leader of the
FMLN, describes
just talking to this general.
And the general rolled
up his sleeve and said,
this is where your forces
shot me in an ambush.
But they'd all been at the
same schools and universities
before they split and
went into the war.
So it was less
emotional, it was more
picking up old acquaintances.
In terms of really
bad things happening,
the trouble is when
bad things happen
they tend to completely
kill off the talks.
And they're very, very
hard to pick up again.
And one of the reasons why it's
always best if you can possibly
get to a ceasefire before you
start public talks is then
the talks won't be
interrupted by these things.
But at the moment in
Colombia, President Santos
is talking to the FARC,
and he's insisting
on fighting and talking
at the same time.
Because President Pastrana,
when he had talks,
gave the FARC an area the
size of Switzerland as a DMZ
that was their area.
And they abused it, and
they went back to fighting.
And so he's determined to keep
the military pressure on them.
The trouble with that
is outrages do happen.
They killed 10
soldiers the other day.
And of course, that
disrupts the talks,
and then people don't
want to carry on.
In the case of the ETA talks,
which were going on in Geneva,
a bomb went off while
the talks were going on.
And the instructions to
the Spanish Government side
were to leave.
They didn't, actually.
They said we're not going
to stay unless you promise
us there won't be
anymore attacks.
So it can be a visceral thing.
But if you want to succeed, you
often have to keep it going.
But keep it going without
giving them perverse incentives.
If you give them
perverse incentives,
it just means the
struggle will go on.
DAVID BLACK: And Jonathan,
closing thoughts.
With the events in
Syria in the news again
today, if you needed to
advise governments on a thing
they should be
doing differently,
what would be your
advice to them?
JONATHAN POWELL:
Well, I think it
would be something I've
already said, really,
which is don't go around
pretending that you're
going to solve this by bombing.
I mean, I know it's
difficult to talk
about what your longer term
strategy is, but please
at least have a
long-term strategy.
The trouble having worked
for a long time in government
is everyone thinks there is
a conspiracy in government.
To tell you the truth, it's
nearly always a cock-up.
Because government doesn't
have the capacity to really
think about things.
What I'd like to think is that
if someone would at least read
the conclusion of
the book, they might
think about how they're going
to tackle ISIS in the long term.
And a whole lot
of people would be
alive who would
otherwise be dead.
DAVID BLACK: Thank you so much
for an absolutely fascinating
talk.
[APPLAUSE]